voyager à l'ère des médias sociaux
changent complètement le rapport à la
nature
pensez à toutes ces photos de paysages
époustouflants esthétiquement parfaite
qui inondent instagram la quête
delinquent devient de plus en plus la
motivation première du voyage avec des
conséquences bien concrètes sur les
lieux visités
justin que de beaux paysages on voit un
peu partout sur instagram conte un peu
comme on peut voir derrière nous
d'ailleurs
mais ce qu'on soupçonne - derrière ça
parfois toute une mise enceinte au
dessus des rendus à josh freed lake en
colombie-britannique
à quoi ça ressemble djafri l'ex folder
premièrement c'est magnifique c'est 3
lac turquoise dans la nature avec des
sapins verts c'est vraiment très beau
puis une photo que les gens vont prendre
aux par là même la même photo c'est une
photo sur une bûche donc un étron dame
qui s'avance dans la khl depuis la rive
les gens peuvent se tenir dessus et
prendre cette photo là la photo est
impossible à rater le magnifique mais ce
qu'on ne sait pas ce qu'on voit pas sur
la photo magnifique c'est qu'il ya des
gens des dizaines de personnes qui font
la file pour prendre exactement la même
photo tous ces éléments-là de la nature
qui finalement aux distorsions par le
biais de ces photos là qu'on prend là
pour représenter le cadre plus idéal
possible aux besoins techniques d'air
qui existe c'est ça je le vois disons en
trois volets premièrement je dirai tout
ce qui filtre modification de la photo
donc dans ton téléphone site ouvre
l'application des caméras savoirs et des
filtres programmé dans l'instant granby
on a des films programmés mais aussi une
pléthore d'applications qui permet de
modifier des photos
deuxième aspect je le verrai comme dans
le cadrage goal com jeudi avec des flux
l'ex c'est d'aller kadri ton coin de
paradis
ça monte risquer de lait sans montrer
les gens qui piétine la végétation et
pleurer possible c'est ça la troisième
façon de métier il faut tous dirais
c'est l'aspect mise en scène d'avoir des
accessoires pour rendre la photo un peu
plus intéressante est par exemple un
hamac howe est une tente pour donner un
moment des déconnexions en nature mais
qui est complètement fabriqué le cges
j'ai apporté ça pour prendre la photo et
tout ça évidemment évolué très vite avec
instagram comment l'industrie du
tourisme se positionne face à tout ça si
on cherchait sur un site touristique des
choses comme ça et puis en plus de tours
guidés vie
et pour instagram moi même je l' ai vécu
quand j'ai visité le canyon en arizona
le tour commence on vient nous chercher
en camionnette on nous amène au canyon
est déjà dans la camionnette
la guide nous dit sortez votre téléphone
ouvrez l'application de caméras aller
dans les filtres cliquer sur vivez de
wine sa lumière très orangé là qui donne
les photos qu'on voit et on gagne on
peut présumer qu'il ya des effets
néfastes sur l'environnement dans
certains lieux au cas où c'est plus
fragiles où c'est plus délicat comme
écosystèmes et justement parlé à un
ancien gardien part que lui décidé de
démissionner parce qu'il y avait trop de
personnes
trop de gens qui jetaient des déchets
trop de gens qui nourrissait les animaux
sauvages et les mettez en danger on l'a
vu ailleurs dans des champs de fleurs
que sont en ontario en californie des
piscines naturelles des endroits comme
ça qui est des petits joyaux cachés de
la nature qui sont pas prêts à faire
face à des hordes de personnes grâce à
cet agrément
[Musique]